- I'd like to welcome colleagues, really,
from all across the
globe as well as the ones
that are actually here in person,
and I guess a special
thanks to Rima Salah.
Shemrah has actually really
been the main organizer
for this event.
And then of course, Crista Marchessealt,
who actually is here at
the Yale Child Study Center
and the Director for Communication,
as well as Angie Ponguta
who's with us online
and she's actually gonna be
monitoring all of the questions
that come in during the various
opportunities that we have
in terms of the question
and answer period.
So as many of you may know,
the Early Childhood Peace
Consortium seeks to engage members
of the community here at
the Yale Child Study Center,
as well as the larger
Yale community and beyond
to explore the evidence,
how we raise our children can be a pathway
to a more peaceful world.
And for the last two decades,
members of the Early
Childhood Peace Consortium
that work together with other members
of the international community,
many of whom are actually
with us this morning
or this afternoon, depending on what area
of the world you live in,
and we are continuing to make the effort
to establish a global movement
to build a more peaceful environment.
And another member has
just arrived, so thank you.
Thank you for being
downstairs. I appreciate it.
So the goal of the Early
Childhood Peace Consortium is
to create a legacy of
sustained peace by drawing
on the transformative power
of early child development.
And the global community
must address the root causes
of violence and conflict
so that the children
and families can be agents
of change for peace.
And I guess I'd want to emphasize
the fact that we also need
to very much engage the
children and the young people
because they are the next generation
and it's gonna matter a lot in terms
of their perspective, as well.
So our first presenter is dear Rima Salah,
who I've known for decades
and she's the current chair
of the Early Childhood Peace Consortium
and she has had all
sorts of important roles
at the United Nations and at UNICEF,
really working in a number of countries
throughout Africa and other places.
But she's also been a member
of our volunteer faculty here
at the Child Study Center,
and it's wonderful that she's here
for us more than a decade.
So I think the floor is yours. Rima.
- Yes. Thank you, thank you, Jim.
Distinguished participants,
dear colleagues,
it gives me a great pleasure to be
with you this morning, this afternoon,
or this evening at the launch
of the new hybrid lecture series,
"Raising Children of Peace" at
the Yale Chart Study Center,
sponsored by the Early
Childhood Peace Consortium.
I am privileged to have the
opportunity to talk to you
on a subject that concerns
us all in these very critical
and trying times,
building a world of peace,
the promise of the Early
Childhood Peace Consortium.
Today, millions of children are trapped
in situations of war, conflict,
displacement and military occupation.
For example, according to
Save the Children report 2021,
approximately 1.6 billion
children were living
in a conflict affected country.
Approximately 449 million children,
over one in six were living
less than five kilometers
from where the active fighting took place.
Some 230 million children lived
in high intensity conflict countries,
this exposing them to
killing, maiming, violence,
abduction, separation from their families,
and denial of humanitarian assistance,
leading to an unprecedented
crisis of care and learning.
Yes, it is the story of lost childhood.
What is alarming
and should concern us all is
the lasting negative impact
of deprivation and violence,
both physical and
structural on young children
and the detrimental effect
on children's development.
Exposure to violence at an
early age is causally related
to a broad range of negative
outcomes across the lifespan,
including major emotional
and behavioral problems
which can be self-perpetuating,
and evidence-based science continues
to substantiate the link
between the early years of life
and the early life environment
with long-term wellbeing.
It also substantiates the link
between violent prevention
and the development of
pro-social behavior that can lead
to more peaceful communities.
Based also on the medical
journal, The Lancet, in 2016,
it is clear that the
formative years of life
and and intra- and inter-family
and community relationships
are powerful agents
of change that can promote resilience,
social cohesion and peace.
Distinguished participants,
the good news and hope is
that the emerging science
heralds a new era,
with windows of opportunities
through the investment
in the positive early
childhood development
of young children as a path,
creating a culture of peace,
sustaining peace at home in
the community and in a society
as a part of social transformation
and violence prevention.
Distinguished participants,
the United Nations
and the international community
also heralds also a new era,
a new vision for building
peaceful societies,
an era where people are
at the center of peace
and development effort,
an era of inclusion with
all members of society,
including families and children
in the service of peace.
The vision was captured by
the United Nations Agenda
for Sustainable Development Goals.
And you know, at the heart
of the agenda is Goal 16,
which advocates to promote
peaceful and inclusive societies
for sustainable development
and provides access to justice
for all and build effective,
accountable and inclusive
institutions at all levels,
the adoption of the
agenda was a particularly,
historical moment for children,
especially the younger
ones and their parents.
The agenda, for the first time,
includes early childhood development (ECD)
and recognized that
it's essential not just
for human development, but also
for sustainable development.
The Secretary General
of the United Nations,
His Excellency Antonio Guterres said,
"Violence against children
is widespread and pervasive,
but is not inevitable.
By placing children at the
heart of the 2030 Agenda
and at the center of all what we do,
we can realize its novel
vision of a world free
from fear, a world free
from violence for all."
End of quotation.
Distinguished participants,
to raise the voice of science,
to join the voice of "we the
people" in this new era for peace
that promotes the participation
of all members of society
in peace building efforts, as such,
calling for innovative and
transformative approaches
that engage family, parents,
and children in the service of peace.
And also, to answer this call of action,
the ECPC was formed and launched at UNICEF
in September, 2013 to join forces
with the international
community to advance global
and national efforts to prevent
violence and build peace
through the transformative power
of early childhood development.
Its founding members include
Yale University, UNICEF,
the Mother and Child
Foundation (ACEV),
Early Years, the organization
for Young Children,
and the United Nations
Alliance of Civilizations.
It also brought together many
distinguished organizations
and partners from multiple
sectors, including civil society,
social and mass media,
government officials,
and bilateral agencies as well
as practitioners and academia.
The consortium's vision is to
create an inclusive movement
for peace, social justice,
and prevention of violence
through using early childhood
development strategies
and services, not only
to mitigate the immediate
and long-term impact of violence
and deprivation on children,
but also to build a strong
foundation for peace, resilience,
social justice, and social cohesion.
Its goals include to
link emerging knowledge
from biobehavioral and
environmental sciences
with existing evidence
to increase investment,
advocate for and create local
and sustainable programs
for peace building and reduction
of violence through ECD,
and also to contribute to
the debate on peace building
by focusing on early
childhood development,
engaging governments, civil
societies, communities,
families and children
through science and practice.
To advocate and disseminate
information for policy makers,
academics, educators,
parents and caregivers,
to build this global movement
that values young children
and families as agents for peace.
Also, to promote and advocate
for the research and programs
of the consortium members
that are taking place
in many areas of the globe
and that contribute to
building peace in societies,
and you will hear from them afterwards.
And most importantly, raise
the voices of families,
parents and children who toil
every day in their cities,
in their villages, in their refugee camps,
to anchor peace in their homes
and in their communities.
We want you to join our movement.
There is no better time
than now for all of us
to unite our strength, to
erect the building blocks
of a peaceful future for all children.
Let us all accompany families,
let us accompany parents,
let us accompany caregivers
in raising children of peace,
and the time is now.
Thank you.
- [Jim] Thank you so much, Rima.
It's always a pleasure
to hear your presentation
and there's so much more
that needs to be done
in this world of ours.
I did prepare a couple of questions,
but I must say you've
answered both of them in terms
of how do we fulfill the promise
of Early Childhood Peace Consortium
and how do we make it into
a more global movement,
and what is the role of universities
and academic institutions like
the Early Child Study Center
in actually making that happen.
So I'm gonna open the floor for questions.
We have a few people in the
audience here in person,
but Angie Portuga, who's
also a member of our faculty,
is actually organizing things with regard
to the opportunities for
people to ask questions.
So, is there anybody in the
audience that has a question
that they would like to ask, or Angie,
can you also indicate
if there are questions
that are coming into you?
- [Angie] No questions
in the chat yet, Jim.
- Okay.
All right, well, I think it's time,
given the timeframe and the
rest of us to introduce Eduardo.
And Eduardo has worked for
decades trying to address issues
of the needs of children and
families affected by conflict,
and he's currently working for UNICEF
and it's been a pleasure
to get to know him.
And although he's been in many
different parts of the world,
he's currently the emergency specialist
for early child development for UNICEF.
So Eduardo, the floor is yours
and hopefully if you
just push this button,
you can advance the slides.
- Okay, terrific.
Thank you so much, Jim,
and what a privilege and
what a pleasure to be here
in this first of a series of lectures
of the Early Childhood Peace Consortium.
I am actually the secretary
of the consortium,
which is not only humbling,
it's a little bit scary
because we have a lot of work to do
and it fills you with
energy to see the names
and the quality of
people in the consortium
and how the enthusiasm and the energy,
it's really moving us
forward in this agenda.
It is also a privilege
and such a pleasure to be
after Rima Salah who is a good
friend who is one of my heroes,
who has been such an incredible
advocate for linking some
of the very important agendas of humanity,
early childhood
development, peace building,
but also other areas that
are a very important link
to the early years of life,
such as gender equality,
climate change, disabilities,
et cetera, et cetera.
So I have a few minutes
with you for the moment.
I think I'm going to come back
and engage much more with the community.
That is so interesting in peace building
and moving the agenda, also,
of early childhood development.
And I wanted to have,
yes, give you a couple
of ideas that are a bit of
a base for future lectures,
but also for food for thought, right?
So I wanted to concentrate in two things.
The first of all is on science,
and Dr. Rima Salah also
mentioned science several times
in her introductory speech, her statement.
And so, I want to sum up hundreds of years
of research and science
in three simple messages.
You see, right?
Hundreds of years, yes, in three messages
and then I'm going to tell you
how also this is translated
for the humanitarian
community, so the ones,
the humanitarian workers
like me who are working
in the field in many countries,
responding to conflict
or to natural disaster,
how we transform all these
messages into commitments
for young children in the field, right?
And then I think we'll have
a space in the weeks to come
or in the months to come to look
at these very specific
examples of programs
and of all the regions
and context of the world.
So first of all, science, and very simply,
what I aspire to do with
this little introduction is
to change your lives.
I am aspiring to change the
way you are looking at life,
the way you are looking at yourself,
the way you are looking at your nephews
or your little nieces or your children
or your grandchildren or your neighbors.
So my three messages are the following.
The first one is
that genetics and environment
are very much linked
and now it's something so clear to us.
Our DNA is not our destiny.
We are going to develop and to unlock
and fold the different skills
and capacities in relation
to the environment that is around us.
And there is an element that
is quite interesting now,
what we have discovered.
We already guessed it before,
but now we have a very
clear evidence for that,
that we human beings as mammals,
we are very social and
we need love and peace
to develop healthy and
to become the best versions of ourselves,
if I can say it that way.
In a way, I'm not going
to talk about epigenetics.
We'll have time for more,
you know, engagement and discussions
but that will be the first message.
The second message is that time matters.
And in my slide I put there,
I did the reference to
the Bucharest study,
which is for me,
it has been one of the
most interesting studies
on early childhood development.
What do I mean by time matters?
So what happens in the brain
of a child is the following.
When we are in the wombs of our mothers,
the neurons starts developing, creating
in the wombs of our mothers
and I think there are
some medicine students
among the distinguished participants
who will be much more articulated
than I am to explain that
in terms of numbers.
But when we are born
with around 100 million,
100 billion neurons, is that correct Jim?
I look at Jim to go for
confirmation. Almost.
The connectivity of those cells,
the synapses is not that big,
but it accelerates in a crazy
way through the engagement
with the environment, to the
age of three, more or less,
those first 1,000 days of life.
The multiplication of this synapses,
this electric connectivity
in the brain, goes insane.
Well, it's not insane. It's
actually something very sane.
But it's very, very, very
strong, at the speed of
around one million new neuronal
connections per second.
And from there, in the
second 1001st of life,
there is a very close
pruning of the brain,
of the child, right?
Pruning meaning there is some
of those connections
disappeared 'cause the brain
of a child becomes very, very specialized.
What it means, this very
early period of life,
is that we have a unique,
incredible window of opportunity
to set up who we are.
And maybe you don't remember
those years of your life,
but that was the most formative,
essential, key moments of your life
that created who you are, right,
this stable opportunity in these few years
to set up empathetic
human beings who are going
to be social, who are
going to be more engaged,
who are going to be
healthier, more skilled.
So all the potential that
we have when we are born,
we have that unique window of opportunity
to support this healthy, happy development
and create the peaceful human
beings who are the elements
of the peaceful communities,
the peaceful families
and the peaceful communities
and the peaceful nations
that we all aspire for.
I am not a determinist.
That doesn't mean that we
cannot do things afterwards.
Of course we are. (chuckles)
We are working with
adolescents and with children
and with adults and with everyone,
the plasticity of the brain,
even if it is incredible in those years
but it exists until we disappear.
My third message is toxic stress,
what our colleagues in the
area are now call toxic stress.
I mentioned toxic stress,
obviously very related
to difficult situations at
home, but also in communities.
Rima has given us very compelling data
on children living in
situations of conflict,
1.6 billion children living in countries
where there is conflict.
What happens when there is toxic stress?
What has happened when we
have a continuous response
of the systems in the body
that responds to that stress?
What happens is there is a risk.
There is a risk of derailment,
of healthy development
and that is not a small
matter because particularly
in situations of emergency or in families
where there is a lot of stress
that turns into toxic stress,
we are risking the development of children
and the consolidation of the creation
of the formation of peaceful
families who are the selves
of peaceful societies.
So three simple messages,
and how do we translate these into action?
And we are going to see that much more
and we have to really explore
much more how we are going
to translate all the science
and all the knowledge
that we have in these
incredible universities
and these amazing academics
that have been studying
for many, many years,
also obviously in partnership
with practitioners,
et cetera, but how do we translate
of this knowledge into action
so we really build those
more peaceful societies?
How can all this science help us
to work effectively and
efficiently in the field,
in the most difficult environments,
in the most difficult
communities and in countries
where there is conflict or
where there is emergencies
and natural disasters that
create a lot of stress
for families and young children?
So we have recently made
this much more official
to say when there is an emergency,
the ones who are working in emergencies
with all the nations
and every woman and man
of goodwill in the world, we
are committing to the children
and we are committing to
the youngest children.
So we have a framework
that help us with this.
We call it the core commitments
for children in humanitarian action.
And recently, we have introduced
these three commitments
for the youngest children in emergencies.
And the three commitments are very simple,
but they have an incredible potential
to transform societies
in the years to come.
The three commitments refers first
to the services we provide to children.
Quality services for the youngest children
in emergency are our priority.
Children have not only to serve,
but they have also the right
to receive those services.
When I started working in
the humanitarian world,
like 30 years ago, I
have to say something.
I was not very committed
to the youngest children
because I was quite unaware of the science
that is behind that I
was explaining before.
And I was thinking as a
humanitarian worker, I was thinking,
"Well, I have to concentrate
in the ones who are suffering the most
and see where we have the biggest impact."
Now I know that those are
actually the youngest children
because the youngest
children don't say, you know,
the children who are one
or two, they don't say,
"Oh my goodness me, my early
development is being derailing.
I need help."
They don't need to say
that because we know it.
We have to provide those services to them,
and services include obviously
health and nutrition,
which is essential up to
75% of nutrients in the body
in the first 1,000 years of life,
go to nourish only one
organ in the body, the brain
'cause it has those
incredible activity, right,
that I mentioned before,
all these new connectivity.
So nutritious good food,
which is not always easy
in countries where they are suffering
from conflict or where there is situations
of natural disaster.
There are many right now.
Health, obviously,
vaccination very basic things,
hygiene, clean hygiene.
We know what E. coli and the
problems of bad hygiene create
in the development of a child.
Protection for the children obviously,
and opportunities for
learning also, right,
these opportunities for
engaging in stimulation.
Having also responsive
caregiving is essential.
So all these services and
quality services are fundamental
for the younger children.
The second obviously is
to support the parents
and the caregivers, to support the mothers
but also the fathers who
have to play a huge role
in the upbringing of children
and the development of the brains
of the youngest ones and caregivers.
And this one refers
also to their wellbeing
and their mental health.
Particularly in situations of emergency,
we are extremely concerned
about the mental health,
the stress and the stressors
that are around families
in situations of emergency,
and finally the capacity
of the frontline workers.
So it's not only the caregivers,
but it's also our doctors,
our nurses, our nutritionists,
our social workers,
our teachers, those
who have direct contact
with children who need
to understand what early
childhood development is,
that they need to participate positively
in that development.
And with that, those three
commitments and three messages,
I thank you all and I am happy
to give back the floor to Jim
and answer any question that, well,
at least to try to answer some
of the questions you are going to ask.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- It's a pleasure, Eduardo,
to hear your presentations
and to be thoughtful
about the work that you're
doing around the world.
And I think you did mention
something about the number
of children that are affected by conflict
and other realities,
and it's really just heartbreaking,
the number of children
that are out there that are
facing these challenges.
So thank you very much
for your presentation.
And you also mentioned some of the things
that are currently ongoing
and UNICEF certainly has
been leading the way,
along with a number of other
international organizations
to try and address the
needs of these children.
And when you think about the realities
in Ukraine and other places
where there's child displacement,
there's separation of family members,
it's really just tragic
and so much more needs to be done.
So I think with that,
I'll open it up for questions
from people in the audience.
Yes. Maria.
- [Maria] So thank you for
the wonderful presentation.
I really appreciate it.
Enjoyed the whole presentation
and the scientific approach for it.
One thing that I was
always wondering about,
I mean the action in emergencies,
the approach from UNICEF is
that given the number of kids,
young kids, that they
might suffer throughout,
I mean ages in different
parts of the globe,
so how UNICEF would prioritize,
I mean, different regions?
I mean, how does the policy
allow you to think about,
"Okay, we have 10
emergencies around the globe
so which one should get the
most, I mean, resources?"
Because I suspect that
the resources are limited.
I mean, we don't have endless
resources. I appreciate it.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
I don't know if people
online, all the millions
of people who are following
online have heard the question,
but it's a great question.
How do we prioritize, right?
In a world where there
is so many challenges,
how do we select one
country or the other or how
to help this community or the other?
The reality is,
and maybe talking also about
the scale of the problem
that maybe I should give a couple of words
on the scale of the problem
to address then, your question
on how to select, right,
how to, I dunno if select is the word,
but how to prioritize.
The reality is that every single child,
and I am a pretty optimistic person
and very positive, I have to say,
so don't get this as a black
cloud now for depressing you,
but the reality is that every single child
in the world today is affected
at least by one crisis.
And one crisis affects every
single child in the world.
You know which one?
Climate, climate, thank
you Jim. Climate change.
And we have had done some
studies from that lately.
We did a report that every single child
of the world is affected
by climate change,
which can affect the development
in one way or the other
from lead to heat shocks
to the development
of every single child in the world.
So that's pretty haunting, right?
If we think about two
of the major indicators
of poor child development,
which I will say is child poverty
and poor nutrition status,
just if we look at child poverty,
we are looking around more
than 200 million children
that we have to target in emergencies,
and so on and so forth.
I mean, there is really hundreds of them.
I can tell you, for example,
an example in Pakistan when
the floats these last year,
the unprecedented floods
in Pakistan affected 36 million people.
I can tell you, the reality is,
there are no enough resources in the world
to address the magnitude
of these problems.
In emergencies usually,
in my team we say we
do what we can, right?
We look for opportunities,
but it's not only financial.
Financial is just one of them.
We look at financial resources,
we look at human resources,
we look at the community resources,
we look at natural resources,
we look at any resources that we can
to address, depending, you know,
ad hoc and different cases.
But there is also very
good news in that sense
because we have incredible partnerships
that are really helping with this.
We have the children themselves
and their family themselves are the best
and the main partners to
address child development.
Obviously, they're the ones
who do 90% of the development,
I will say, of the youngest children.
And we have to work with
them as real partners.
We have to go and in that case,
UNICEF has a little
bit of the UN agencies.
We have an advantage there
because we go hand in hand with everyone,
including the governments and authorities
that also have a fundamental role to play.
It's a puzzle of partnerships, of hands
that are going to help the children,
with the children and the families,
with the families to address all those.
And yes, also one little
important point there.
When there is emergencies,
when there is conflict,
we do what we can.
Conflict by definition is the opposite
of a conducive environment
for development.
So, buffer those environments
to create better
environments for development.
That's what we do and we do
as much as we can. (laughs)
Thank you.
- Well, thank you
and I think we're running
a little bit short of time,
but Angie, I think there's time at least
for one question coming
from the virtual community.
Is there anything that
comes that you've seen?
- [Angie] There is.
There is one question from Hinako,
and feel free to open
up your mic and share it
if there's enough time.
If not, I've said that we
will pass it on to Eduardo
and then reply to it in
written communication
as a briefing to the presentations.
- Well, why don't you go ahead
and have the person pose the question
and I'm sure that Eduardo
will be able to answer.
- [Angie] Okay.
Hinako, would you like
me to read it for you?
Or please feel free to open up your mic.
- [Hinako] Yeah, I'm happy to ask.
Hello, my name is Hinako
and I'm currently a graduate student
at the Harvard Graduate
School of Education
and a mentee of ambassador
Anwarul Chowdhury.
And so my question is,
a lot of my course's
conversation was about sort
of the protective factors of
early childhood development,
sort of adults thinking
about how to protect children
but I'm really curious
because I think it's so unique
and powerful to think
about young children themselves
being the agents of peace.
And so, I would sort of love to hear,
what skills should we be
focusing on fostering.
What are the developmentally
appropriate ways to recognize
and nurture the sense of agency
for peace among young children?
Yeah.
- Hinako, thanks. What a great question.
Thank you very much.
I mean, when you mentioned young children,
you refer to adolescents, if I am correct?
- [Hinako] I was thinking
more like early childhood.
- Oh wow, okay.
- [Hinako] Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah. Oh, that's a good question.
I'm going to address or try
to address a little bit both.
The youngest children are
not only victims of crisis.
They are also the biggest
asset to address crisis.
And through the investments in
early childhood development,
we are looking at early
childhood development
and the best ways to
construct cohesive societies,
not only for the future,
but in the moment of
the emergencies, also.
One of the good things I have to say
in emergency is that
the youngest children,
the children under eight are
not controversial in many ways.
Well, everything can be controversial,
but I will say it's one
of the least controversial things, right?
To feed and to support children,
the younger children is going to be one
of the driving factors for social cohesion
and for addressing emergencies.
The children, the youngest children.
- [Jim] We may be asking
you to respond also
and you can send a message
to Angie for the remainder
because we're running a little short.
- Yeah, and we want Siobhan.
Let's do that, and then
we take this further
because also, we can talk about
the younger and bit older,
the adolescents being engaged
on supporting early childhood development
as the best advocates to do so.
Thanks, Jim.
- Thank you. Muchos Gracias.
So I'm gonna turn the
floor over to Siobhan,
but it's also fascinating
because one of the things
that she's been working on,
and I'm not sure if Sherry
Westin's in the audience or not,
but when you think about "Sesame
Street" and the rest of it,
but she's gonna be actually
sharing with us some
of the things that she's been
doing in Northern Ireland
and in Ireland in general
to address this issue.
So I think I will move ahead with this.
And Siobhan is actually
the current chairperson
of the International
Network on Peace Building
for Young Children,
and she's also the former
chief executive officer
of Early Years, the
Organization for Young Children.
And Early Years is a
non-profit organization
that's been working since
1965 to promote peace
and high quality childcare for children
and their families based
in Northern Ireland.
So I'm not sure, Siobhan,
if you're actually able
to advance the slides
but I can do that if you need me to.
- [Siobhan] Yeah, I think you're
going to do it for me, Jim.
- Pardon me?
- [Siobhan] I think you're
going to do it for me.
I think that's what I was told,
that you would advance the slides.
Many thanks. Good afternoon,
good morning everyone.
Greetings from Northern Ireland.
I'm sorry I can't be with
you there in the auditorium,
but perhaps sometime
during the lecture series.
In this session, I hope
to describe to you how we
as an organization pioneered
a culture of respect
for difference with young children
and hopefully, I'll be able to
answer some of the questions
that have been raised so far.
Our work was not only with young children,
but also with their teachers and parents
against a backdrop of a
deeply divided society scarred
and traumatized by 30 years of conflict.
I will describe to you how
we developed a new program,
the Media Initiative
Respecting Difference Program,
and implemented this
across Northern Ireland,
Ireland and beyond
and also subjected it to
a variety of evaluations,
including a large random control trial.
As Jim has said, the
organization was founded in 1965,
just a few short years before the outbreak
of conflict in 1969.
And it was always committed
to creating a cross community,
non-sectarian approach,
ensuring that the two
main traditions then,
Catholics and Protestants,
Republican Nationalist,
Loyalist Unionist families
could come together
where parents could get to know each other
and children could begin to play together.
Against the backdrop
of what we euphemistically
call The Troubles,
The Northern Ireland
Conflict 1969 to 1994,
these services for young
children provided a safe space
for parents across the religious divide
and provided opportunities
to support one another
through the horror that
was unfolding around them.
After the cease fires in 1994 and
with investment by the European Union
in the special support program
for peace and reconciliation,
investment in early
childhood services was seen
and still is seen as
one of the key vehicles
for building the peace
in Northern Ireland.
The signing of the Good Friday Agreement
in 1998 was a significant
step forward in terms
of taking the gun out of Irish politics.
The Good Friday agreement
with a focus on rights,
social justice and reconciliation
presented a very positive,
policy environment for the development
of services for young children.
Given our long history of
supporting high quality,
non-sectarian, evidence-informed
early year services,
we were confident that early
childhood services could play,
an ever increasing role in the quest
for social cohesion and peace building.
Thank you, Jim, for
sharing this next slide
because the publication
of this research in 2001,
"Too Young to Notice?"
was a wake up call
for us all in the early childhood sector.
The research presented the
harsh reality that children
as young as three in Northern Ireland,
while developing positive
aspects of their own identity,
were however developing negative,
prejudicial attitudes to others.
And as you can see, by the age of six,
these attitudes were becoming embedded.
The research also challenged
a prevailing view at the time
that young children were too young
to notice the sectarian
divisions that surrounded them.
This research was a catalyst
for us in the organization
to rethink our approach to
dealing with issues of race,
religion, ethnicity and identity.
And we took an explicit,
intentional approach to move
from being a non-sectarian organization
to becoming an
anti-sectarian organization.
We were supported with a range
of multi-level stakeholder
partnerships including media,
academia, education
partners, policy makers
to work collaboratively to
develop a new Early Years program
that became known as the Media Initiative.
Next slide please, Jim.
The program aimed to develop a
respecting difference culture
that celebrated the variety of differences
in Northern Ireland society.
And while ethnic and
religious differences had been
at the heart of our conflict,
there was a recognition of the need
to celebrate other emerging differences
on the basis of race, disability, gender,
and also promote an
anti-bullying, respectful culture
that would underpin relationships
between children, parents,
teachers, and the wider community.
The program had a number
of distinct new components,
the development of five
persona characters,
representing religious, physical, ethnic,
and race differences,
the development of five
cartoon television messages,
reflecting instances of
exclusion and inclusion.
These messages were initially played
on national television
regularly throughout the year
and were watched by children,
parents, and the wider community.
The development of a new curriculum
and service design manual aimed
at supporting preschool teachers
implement this new approach
in a culturally and
contextually appropriate manner,
new training for preschool
teachers and parents based
on reflective techniques
that helped parents
and teachers reflect on their
own experience of difference
and supporting them to
understand and respect the other.
The development of new resources reflect
in the religious, cultural,
sporting and musical traditions
within a divided society,
capacity building for management
committees, school leaders
so that they could support the development
of anti-sectarian policies and strategies
within their local services
and their local communities.
This new program was influenced
by the need to move away
from a superficial approach to dealing
with religious, race and ethnic issues.
Traditionally in Northern Ireland,
early childhood programs had
adopted a neutral approach
to such issues, which in fact
meant they were often ignored.
We wanted to move away from approaches
that supported limited
contact for children
from different religious,
ethnic and socioeconomic backgrounds
and were keen to create deep, meaningful,
prolonged daily experiences
for children, families, and teachers.
We were influenced by
theorists on social cohesion
that stressed the importance
of building trust,
respect for each other
and a sense of belonging.
The program was initially
targeted at three
and four year olds,
but has since been extended
to work with two year olds
and eight year olds in
full daycare settings
and in afterschool environments.
We were introducing a new approach,
an approach that took an
intentional, anti-sectarian,
contextually appropriate
focus to the issues
that had caused enormous division
within Northern Ireland society.
Sport, music, cultural activities
and flags were often symbols of division
across Northern Ireland society.
And yet, this new approach
intentionally use these symbols
of division to create a culture
of respect and understanding difference.
It was vitally important,
therefore, that evidence ensured
that the approach was
not further exacerbating
at the situation and creating
even further divisions.
Next slide please, Jim.
Between 2003 and 2010,
Early Years continued to develop
and implement the program
and with support from
Atlantic Philanthropies,
we were able to commission
Queen's University
in Belfast, Stranmillis College
and the National Children's Bureau
to carry out a random control trial,
involving 80 preschool settings
in both Northern Ireland
and the Republic of Ireland
and this was coupled
with a number of qualitative case studies.
The results were a positive indication
that the Media Initiative was
having a significant impact
in supporting young children's social
and emotional development
and creating a culture
of inclusion and respecting difference.
The positive results from
the random control trial
and the qualitative care
studies brought both political
and founder attention to
the innovative approach.
And over the next decade,
investment for implementation
and going to scale was provided
by a number of sources.
Since 2010 until now,
Early Years has developed
a systematic approach
to both scaling up and implementation.
The approach has involved
developing a scaling up strategy,
establishing implementation
teams and detailed advocacy
and sensitization strategy
to convince case stakeholders
to support implementation
and provide political,
financial and institutional
sustainability.
Since its inception,
the program has been
adapted and implemented
in a range of local and global context.
The program has been successfully
implemented and evaluated
in the Western Balkans, in
Kyrgyzstan and Tajikistan
and it is hoped that we
will implement the program
in Palestine, Israel, and Columbia.
The Media Initiative has also
been a significant component
in the new Shared Education
program in Northern Ireland
and the Republic of
Ireland through the Sharing
from the Start project,
funded by the European Union.
And this program aims to
provide young children
with even greater
educational opportunities
to be educated together,
rather in the segregated system
that has been the system to date.
In subsequent lectures, I hope
to share with you the details
on the International Network
on Peace Building and perspectives
from key global partners who have adapted
and implemented the model
that has been developed
in Northern Ireland.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Siobhan.
I'm not sure we have
time for many questions,
but it does bring to mind
the work of Sesame Workshop
and all the work that they've been doing.
I think they have their
programs in present,
at least in 150 countries around the world
and by interacting and
directly having an impact
on young children and their parents,
are making a real
difference around the globe.
But are there any questions
from the audience?
And Angie, anybody have a question
that they've posed to you?
- [Angie] Not in the chat.
- Okay, well I think in
that case we may move on,
but thank you again Siobhan
for your presentation
and we are optimistic in terms
of what the realities are
in Northern Ireland
and you've been having an
important impact for decades.
So thank you, thank you, thank you.
So here just is a picture
of Angie Ponguta who's leading the chat,
Kyle Pruett who I will be
ending this afternoon's session,
and also a picture of
Catherine Panter-Brick
who's one of the individuals
that's been helping lead the way.
But there's actually, here
at Yale is actually the head
of one of the residential colleges,
Morris College here at Yale.
And thoughts to the families that we serve
to say nothing of our own
children and grandchildren
and as a father and grandfather,
this is a real issue for
me and I want to hear
from the audience what your thoughts are
about how it has to encourage,
inspire, and motivate the
next generation to join us,
to build a more peaceful world.
We need to work together
to make that happen,
and I guess I would be
interested in your thoughts
about how best to proceed
with that reality.
It also makes me think of a
few quotes from Mahatma Ghandi
and Nelson Mandela as well as
this book that we put together
that was published back in 2014,
"Pathways to Peace:
The Transformative Power
of Children and Families"
where we brought together 70
different experts with regard
to a whole range of issues
from basic science to policy
to talk about the realities
in how to address this issue
with regard to building
a pathway to peace.
But I'll just read the two
quotes from Ghandi and Mandela.
"If we're here to teach
real peace in this world
and if we are to carry on
a real war against war,
we must begin with the children
and you must help them be the change
that you wish to see in the world.
And there can be no keener
revelation of the society's soul
than the way it treats its children."
So positive wellbeing
and healthy development,
young children starting
in utero has been linked
to protective, safe,
responsive, supportive,
and stimulating environments.
So that's a thought to
Eduardo's presentation as well.
And we need to do all we can
to foster positive parents
for all the parents that we serve,
to say nothing of our families
and it's one family at a
time, one child at a time
and we need to make a real difference.
Children have to be loved,
protected and well-nourished
to promote peace.
And children, even young
children need to have a voice
and agency to promote peace.
So with that, I will leave
the floor open for questions
and thank you all for joining us today,
and any questions from the audience?
Well in that case, I'll turn
the floor over to Angie.
And any answers to the
questions that I posed?
- [Angie] Not to your remarks.
There was a question
that I will send directly
to Siobhan in the interest of time.
- Well, why don't you go ahead,
'cause we're running a little over time,
but I think given the fact
that we're actually recording
this and the rest of it,
I would really like to hear
from the participant
what question they had.
- [Angie] Sure.
Blythe, if you would like
to open your microphone up,
please do so.
If not, I'm happy to
transfer across you. Mhm!
- [Blythe] I'm a past chair
of the Peace Education Sig
of the American Educational
Research Association.
And at the time that I was chair,
we did work with doctors
Ian and Ian from Ireland.
And my question was,
how is the work that you
have just reported related
to their work over the years?
- I think that's a
question for you, Siobhan.
- [Siobhan] Yeah, thank you Blythe.
I am also aware of their work,
but this work that I've
spoken about was a combination
of work from Queen's
University, Dr. Paul Connolly
and Dr. Alan Smith in
the University of Ulster.
But naturally, there is an overlap
with the work that the Ians
have been doing here as well.
- [Blythe] Thank you.
- So I think I'd like to
end today's presentations
with a quote from Kyle Pruett,
who unfortunately is not able to join us,
but he is a graduate of Yale College.
He's also a Whiffenpoof,
which is one of the singing
organizations that is well known
across the globe in terms of their talent.
And he's actually composed
and has been working
with children and we're not able
to hear the song itself today,
but I will quote and it's
called "Seeds of Peace."
I will just quote the first stanza.
"Welcome to our world, my
child. Come to our world.
With each new life,
we have a chance to
plant the seeds of peace.
Holding your tiny hands
nestled in our own,
we hold you close throughout the night
'til the morning sun returns.
Feeling safe at home, sows
the seeds of peace.
So with that, I think
I will thank everyone
for participating today,
and looking forward
to hearing the final version
of that that will be recorded
and believe it or not,
from a series of children
as well as with Kyle.
So, thank you all very much
and it's been a pleasure
and honor to be here and I'm
grateful for all of the support
that we've received and I'm
very grateful, so thank you.
(bird flapping wings)
(gentle jingle)